the reason why certain people turn to
philosophy
why i became a philosopher was that
since i was a little boy
i always felt that
[Music]
existence as such
was weird
i mean
here we are
isn't that odd
of course it's odd
what do you mean what do you mean by odd
well it's what's different from even
i mean what's art stands out
what's even lies flat
but you can't see
the outstanding without the flat
background
[Music]
here's this thing standing out
it's odd
each one of you is odd
strange unique particular different
how do we know what we mean by that
except against the background of
something even
that is not differentiated like space
and so you get this philosophical itch
you begin to scratch your head and think
about why is that so
[Music]
well after a while you realize that's a
meaningless question
and you ask how is it so
well that leads you into science
and other investigations
so you want to know what is it
i mean this this happening this thing
called existence what is it
you ask that question long enough and it
suddenly hits you
[Music]
that if you could answer it
you wouldn't know what terms to put the
answer in
i mean when we investigate the
properties of nature
and we do get some answers
all the answers are in terms of
particular structures
forms patterns
and these can be measured
and their behavior can be predicted
[Music]
but when i want to ask the question what
are the forms made of
i mean what is it really
we can't think of any way in which we
could
answer the question
because we would have to have
a class of all classes
when you ask the question what
it's like saying
is you is or is you ain't
is you animal is your vegetable is your
mineral
are you a republican or a democrat are
you male or female
are you a christian or a jew or a hindu
or what have you
we classify
always to give an answer to the question
what is it
and when you classify you distinguish
an inside group from an outside group
[Music]
right so what we want to know is what is
the group of all groups
well we can't imagine what the outside
would be
so we can't answer the question
what is it
so the physicist finally abandoned
the quest for stuff
and they gave us a description of the
universe
entirely in terms of form
[Music]
the pattern not the stuff
when people ask what's the web yeah but
you can't do that what's the pattern
made of
surely there mustn't be an answer to
that
see what happens is when you turn up the
microscope
all stuff
turns into form
it becomes articulate you know the
carpet looks like some sort of stuff
but
when you look at it under a microscope
you will see the crystalline structure
of the nylon or whatever it's made of
see they want to know what are those
crystals made of
all right
turn up the volume
and you'll find
molecules
turn up the volume
you find waveables
but we think the the the wavelengths
must be of something
but of course they're not
we find substance or stuff totally
vanishes
we say does it matter
what does that mean
[Music]
does it matter is it important
in other words does it measure up to
anything
mata
comes from a sanskrit root matra
which means to measure
so from this root matra we get going on
into sanskrit we get the word maya
and maya is generally translated
illusion
although it also means magic
creative power
the word illusion switch over
we get that from latin
and that comes from the latin ludere to
play
let's pretend
that we matter
see the world is a musical phenomenon
good music
never refers to anything except the
music itself
you don't ask mr black mr ravi
what do you mean
by this music
what is it intended to express
listen
that's the meaning
giraffes are giraffing trees are treeing
stars are starring clouds are clowning
rain is raining
and if you don't understand look at it
again
and people are people
wow
we notice that all these
suchnesses
appear and disappear they keep changing
they come and they go
but if you get hung up on your
particular form
i'll have to alter the language a little
bit because you see your form makes a
duality
whereas you are your form
you're what you're doing
now you think
um
for some strange reason i
must make that go on as long as possible
and therefore you think you have an
instinct to survive
and so the only thing anybody can agree
about today
so far as the discussion of ethical and
moral problems are concerned
is that we ought to survive
and therefore certain forms of conduct
have survival value and certain forms
don't
but when you say to yourself you must go
on living
you put yourself in a double blind
because you said to a process which is a
sense essentially spontaneous
that it must happen
and the basic form of the double bind
which is imposed upon all children
is you are required to do that which
will be acceptable only if you do it
voluntarily
so when we say to ourselves
you must go on
the reason is you see
that we are not living in the eternal
now
where reality is
we are always thinking that the
satisfaction of life will be coming
later
don't kid yourself
which is to say
only suckers
put hope in the future
you